let's go to is it Lewis from New
Brunswick or or Lois it's just cut off I
apologize
something with an Lo from New Brunswick
oh good afternoon David it's a Louie
Louie welcome what's on your mind today
well I just want to thank you I love
your show thank you been listening for a
long time pleasure uh a couple months
ago you had a piece with author
Jefferson Morley yes
he's known for JFK research and stuff um
my question for you is
do you think the uh the government's
response to the JFK case which a lot of
I guess polls show that a lot of people
are a little skeptical
on the official conclusions uh do you
think that's fueled all of this
recent uh I I don't know how to say it
uh destabilization with like conspiracy
theories and just lack of like General
consensus you're saying is the lack of
credibility of the government's position
on the JFK assassination fueling other
modern conspiracy theorism
yeah do you think it like it it like
laid a a groundwork that or we haven't
really reaped the full of uh uh you know
damage of until now I don't think so I
don't think so I mean there's
interesting stuff going on with JFK
right now in fact I recorded a tick tock
earlier this week which we're going to
publish in Jefferson Morley wrote about
recently how on December 15th I believe
it is is the deadline imposed a year ago
by the Biden Administration to release a
whole bunch of new documents and we'll
see about the JFK assassination and
we'll see if they are or aren't and
there are some who are saying this is
going to be an incredible bombshell or
something like that I don't know I don't
think that no I I don't think that the
JFK assassination specifically
um has much to do with with modern
conspiracism I think it's lack of
critical thinking social media Echo
Chambers people who don't know how to
think for themselves and evaluate claims
lack of epistemological skills I I think
it's all of that really
oh interesting all right thanks a lot I
appreciate the call all right Louie from
New Brunswick thank you very very much
for the call let's go to Grant from Ohio
Grant welcome to the program what's on
your mind today hey David um I was just
wondering if you could give your
thoughts um because I don't think you've
talked about it yet about the Biden and
um his administration not siding with
the railroad uh unions when I believe
all they wanted was paid sick leave and
there was an interesting interview I
think Jake Tapper did a pretty good
interview with Pete Buda judge a couple
days of grilling I'm on it but um I just
find it kind of hypocritical because
Biden says he's the best pro-union
and labor president or a lifetime but
he's not signing with the railroad
workers and all they want is paid sick
leave so listen a lot of that was
happening as I was sort of falling into
my covid uh uh fit period and so I did
not follow the story as closely as I
would have liked but my understanding of
the Biden position on this was listen
they're not getting everything but
they're getting a bunch of stuff they
want and it's really important to
prevent the strike now you can take the
position
that the Biden Administration
should not be
forcefully working in any way to prevent
a strike particularly if they claim to
support both unions and workers rights
to strike and I am very sympathetic to
that idea but it seems that the argument
that the Biden Administration is making
is
if this strike were to happen here are
all of the ways in which it would be a
disaster for different aspects of the
American people because of the Reliance
that is that is taking place on
railroads and a lot of their demands
were met
and so we think that they should not
strike but I think it's perfectly
legitimate to say that it's a government
overreach to actually prevent the strike
I agree with that too and it's also
frustrating when these CEOs and like the
leaders of these railroads are making
record profits too and
um yeah I just think it's frustrating it
is absolutely frustrating there's no
doubt about that
all right well that was all thank you
all right thanks Grant there is Grant